In Venezuela, former presidential candidate and opposition leader Henrique Capriles...
...says no dialogue is possible with the government of Nicolas Maduro.
In Somalia, a Shabaab suicide bomber rammed a vehicle loaded with explosives...
...into an African Union military base.
Seven women members of a family were injured...
...when a mortar shell fired by Pakistani troops hit their house...
...in the border region of India's northern state of Punjab.
Workers in France begin demolishing the Calais migrant "Jungle,"...
...with officials hoping that its thousands of residents evacuate peacefully.
And finally from South Sudan, the UN fears an "explosive effect" of hate speech...
...attributed to members of South Sudanese President Salva Kiir's ethnic Dinka group against Equatorians.